okay Jessica here we go you are a latina
woman who's in support of the wall how
do you exist my stories like this my dad
is a GUI okay so what Akoya is in
spanish is a smuggler a human trafficker
I wake up sometimes and there'd be a
room packed full of people I've never
met
whoa and we lived in a small apartment
so it was like I had a share space with
complete strangers how many people let's
say twelve it was kind of awkward but
that's the word I would use to describe
waking up to a roomful of twelve illegal
immigrants is awkward a little awkward
yeah what do you think of those people I
don't know these people I don't know who
they are what they've done now that I
think about is an adult I'm like how the
hell did my parents do that right that
directly seems super unsafe and weird
and creepy yeah maybe even a little and
I don't like to use extreme language
l-word
but um I'm sure those people from their
perspective we're sitting there gone I
feel terrible for this little girl I'm
just like so desperate on what else am I
supposed to do here do you see it like
that or do you just say it doesn't
matter how desperate you were it doesn't
really matter how desperate you are you
know because here's here's my
perspective on the wall the difference
between like my father back in the 80's
90's to today is that you have people
like my dad pushed out and now it's ran
by the cartels which obviously is like a
whole other world so is that your main
problem with illegal immigration at this
point that it's become co-opted by
criminal enterprise that's one of the
reasons what do you think that Donald
Trump's wall will accomplish to stop the
cartels and to stop the illegal
immigration it would actually do a
couple things so what it would do is one
we got the problem of human trafficking
so we're not only getting human
trafficking from people that just want
to come here and make a better life
we're getting us sex slavery child
trafficking we're getting so many
different types of trafficking that are
not by their own will so you're saying
that the cartels that are worth billions
of dollars right some of those powerful
criminal enterprises in the world world
you don't think they can afford a ladder
let me get the bleep dude I mean if art
I mean depends what kind of wall we're
going to have right
and it's not going to just be a physical
concrete wall I'm sure there's going to
be some kind of new technology girls
like sensors and lasers which you never
know I mean we are we going to need that
because the Mexican people and the
people from the South are very resilient
and we're very ingenious we'll figure it
out
yeah I can't be just made out of
concrete plus through it would you
prefer if we went back to small
mom-and-pop of Coyote operations no I
prefer that we didn't do any coyote
uppers let's say we have to if we have
to yeah put your dad back in business I
feel like I've trust my dad more than
the I trust her done implicitly oh
that's so sweet how does he feel about
the wall oh how well he's out of that
business now he's been out he's been
help so long he does construction and
over there and economy um probably like
built house house house what's what's a
house made of Oh like this wood roof I'm
in the wood but then the roof and then
what homes right he's a construction are
you trying to get me there hell I'm not
trying to get you into objects tell me
what a house is made of wood and what's
the world what are the flat parts on the
side called what oh they're wood oh what
house yeah but what's inside of a house
what's a house made up what floors
floors and what what's on the side I
don't know man what's that
say the word wall money longer whoa your
father builds a wall anyway thank you
very much for being thank you I
appreciate you
[Music]